ti markine passons à l'actualité
culturelle si j'ose dire il a dix ans
mourait pablo picasso l'un des peintres
les plus importants de notre siècle
l'oeuvre de picasso est tellement
gigantesque qu'à sa mort il a laissé des
milliards un tel ou tel a été sans
problème d'ailleurs d'abord à cause de
son importance ensuite parce que le
peintre a vécu une vie familial plutôt
mouvementée à plusieurs reprises depuis
ces dix dernières années elle a parlé
dans la presse dans les applications
bien s'amuser il n'est toujours pas
ouvert dix ans après autant de raisons
qui font que jean jacques dufour et
pascal piot et voulu nous dresser le
bilan
picasso
picasso né à malaga en 1880 à
transformer influencé toute l'histoire
de la peinture mondial du 20e siècle
c'est le peintre dès l'hiver les
tableaux l'une des oeuvres maîtresses de
son oeuvre
il l'a pas un pari en avril 37 date du
bombardement de guernica pendant la
guerre civile espagnole et juin de la
même année était le temps les mails de
cette toile je vais tuer ses effets avec
des intentions tellement du moment de
l'époque et les talents l'équerré tout
le monde et moi qui ai fait le déficit
augmente de guernica est fermé car
c'était une grande catastrophe
mais comment ces marais beaucoup
d'autres que nous avons suivi
g
exceptionnel met face à face aux chants
des mémoires conscrits soi même des
cahiers c'est au mali c'est un fabuleux
héritage culturel et financier car son
oeuvre commencé ici en espagne dans cet
atelier couvre presque un siècle
d'histoire de la peinture en chiffres
cela représente environ 2000 tableau 15
mille dessins plus de 1000 sculptures
des milliers de gravures et des terrains
le tout estimé à 120 milliards de
centimes une somme qui explique la potée
des discussions entre les ayants droit
d'autant que se réfugiant derrière une
vieille superstition catalan qui assure
que celui qui rédige son testament signe
son arrêt de mort picasso n'a pas laissé
de volonté et crypte
en revanche il a offert aux avocats une
situation de famille compliquée
c'était marié s'était mariée une
première fois avec madame complot va
quand il a vu un fils légitime
il avait ensuite des enfants naturels et
puis s'était remariée avec la
publication il a fallu donc de régler
les communautés plus et succession tout
ça s'est déroulé assez bien les hauts et
des bas finalement déterminé à l'accord
global et un partage qui semble avoir
donné satisfaction tout le monde sur
l'héritage de 120 milliards de centimes
l'état qui 30 milliards le reste 90
milliards a été partagée entre jacques
pin rock deuxième femme légitime de
picasso claude maillard et paloma les
enfants adultérins et les petits enfants
qui ne sont plus que deux marinas et
bernard pablito s'étant suicidé en 1973
pour payer les droits de succession les
héritiers donner des oeuvres à l'état ce
qui me constitue possible depuis 68 et
cela s'appelle une dation
malheureusement ce fabuleux trésor n'est
pas encore dans le musée devrait
l'abrité c'est ici dans les sous-sols du
palais de tokyo
et pourtant c'est en 74 que michel guy
ouvrait le dossier
il s'agissait de nommer un conservateur
vraiment besoin de le faire là d'opérer
la dation c'est le choix de l'étain ce
que dominique bozo et les marion fait et
puis devenir un bâtiment ce que j'ai
fait avec lequel ça les met à
disposition par la ville de paris
et puis aussi de nommer un architecte
pour aménager le musée alors simonet en
76 tout ça était terminé après les
ministres se sont succédé et aujourd'hui
l'hôtel salé et le musée picasso n'est
toujours pas ouvert
il s'agit sans doute de ce qu'on appelle
les pesanteurs administratives et
j'avais le plus tôt les négociations
trois françaises qui complique beaucoup
les dossiers il faut une volonté
politique très forte pour faire aboutir
ce qu'ils prêchent cette magnifique
collection des picasso de picasso qui
appartient désormais à la france la
voici
au total 230 peinture 140 sculpture près
de 15 cents des simples elles de seissan
gravure 85 céramique et puis des objets
personnels et des manuscrits dominique
bozo conservateur en explique
l'importance
la surprise de la nation nous trouver
dans l'application des oeuvres ne
soupçonnait pas qu'il avait gardé sa
aussi bien des oeuvres qui ont contribué
à aucun grand de création autour des
mêmes d'avignon du cubisme et avoue
presque insoupçonnées et également tout
ce qui est autour de sa vie familiale
dans sa vie personnelle jusqu'à jusque
là comme celui ce musée encore en
chantier mais qui devra permettre au
public d'en libérer de façon permanente
ces chefs-d'oeuvre le voici
c'est l'hôtel salé situé dans le marais
un ouvrage du xviie siècle classé
monument historique
nous avons demandé à monsieur jacques
lang quand on allait enfin pouvoir
assister à l'inauguration
lorsque je suis arrivé au ministère de
la culture
les travaux étaient mobilisées lé
dossier traîner les procédures
ralentissez l'ensemble des travaux et
nous avons pris la faire à bras le corps
et je peux vous dire qu'avant 18 - ce
magnifique musée sera ouvert au public
souhaitons donc que pour le 12e
anniversaire de la mort de picasso
ce musée soit ouvert car le peintre nous
a fait un grand honneur en choisissant
d'aimer la france